nous sommes avec Jean vandrou le
président de la Fondation Anne De Gaulle
bonjour bonjour à vous aujourd'hui une
pierre symbolique a été posée la
Fondation s'installe à Montini déjà
Montini brotonux pourquoi alors au-delà
de la première pierre vous l'avez bien
compris c'est vraiment le lancement d'un
d'un mouvement 100 % inclusif pourquoi
Montini ben écoutez parce que en fait
l'occasion s'est présentée d'acquérir
une très grande percelle en pleine ville
et dans un environnement qui reste très
apaisant très accompagnant avec ses ses
arbres cette verdure et pour nous
c'était vraiment le le premier défi
qu'on a dû relever vous pensez bien que
c'est compliqué dans une agglomération
comme Saint-Quentin de trouver une telle
superficie et là je veux saluer
naturellement l'aide des services de
l'État et du préfet Jean-Jacques Brou en
particulier qui a eu un un rôle
déterminant avec le maire Laurin mercart
donc effectivement vous l'écosystème est
absolument exceptionnel puisque comme
vous l'avez compris également un des
grands messages est celui de de
l'innovation de de solutions nouvelles
d'accompagnement mais pas que une
fondation qui devient également un
espace de de recherche et et
d'enseignement à côté de cette
plateforme d'hébergement et pour ça
peut-on rêver mieux sur notre territoire
que la communauté de Saint-Quentin avec
la faculté de Saint-Quentin à quelques
encablur le plateau de sacelet Tout le
tout le maillage territorial et
économique scientifique du territoire
qui est tout à fait exceptionnelle en
île-de-fance et dans notre pays on parle
d'un village inclusif on va y retrouver
de tout tout le monde sera accueilli sur
le terrain pendant trop
longtemps l'accueil et l'accompagnement
des personnes en situation de handicap
en institution se faisait de façon
relativement cloisonnée et
compartimentée bien sûr que des
structures comme celle-là doivent
exister et doivent se développer parce
que certaines personnes ont besoin
d'un environnement extrêmement sécurisé
mais dans l'immense majorité des cas il
faut tout faire encore une fois pour que
chaque personne en situation d'hicap
soit un citoyen comme les autres et
puisse faire valoir son droit à
l'autodétermination en particulier de
choisir là où ils veulent vivre et
comment ils veut vivre et précisément ce
village qui est ouvert vers la ville va
permettre de leur proposer la solution
adaptée à leurs besoins leur permettre
de déambuler à l'intérieur du village
mais également dans la commune avoir
accès aux activités de loisirs aux
activités culturelles bref de vivre
comme tout à chacun mais pour que ça
marche pour que ça marche il faut que
les personnes qu'ils vont rencontrer sur
leur chemin soient en capacité de
communiquer avec elle et c'est tout
l'idée justement d'accompagner la
société à devenir accompagnante en leur
en donnant à chaque citoyen des clés de
communication très simple mais qui nous
permettent à toutes et tous de rentrer
en relation avec ces personnes tous les
handicaps seront pris en charge vous
êtes sur du trouble cognitif trisomi 21
le le le le le public qui est hébergé
dans nos dans nos structures sont des
personnes présentant une déficience
intellectuel et ce qu'on appelle un
trouble du neurodéveloppement qui
comprend un éventail très large de
troubles de déficience intellectuel dont
les troubles du spectre autistique euh
mais effectivement notre notre cœur de
métier je dirais et d'expertise c'est
les troubles du neurodéveloppement et la
déficience intellectuelle alors vous
l'avez dit très vite parce qu'il y aura
un laboratoire que vous l'avez pensé en
quatre
maisons alors il y a effectivement
quatre maisonnés d'habitat d'habitat
j'insiste sur le terme d'habitat parce
que vraiment c'est c'est vraiment le
cœur du projet que ces personnes se
sentent comme chez elles et puis deux
autres maisonné que nous autorise la
réserve ère de notre terrain d'ailleurs
permis de construire doit être déposé
dans les tous prochains jours dont l'un
des ces bâtiments a vocation à
accueillir le premier campus recherche
dédié à 100 % à
l'inclusion et à l'accompagnement de
l'ensemble de notre territoire ville
dans un premier temps mais au-delà
naturellement ce projet a vocation à se
répliquer partout en France voilà pour
rendre la société accompagnante et
permettre partout par tous à tout moment
la rencontre accompagnée leur donner une
certaine autonomie finalement au cœur de
la société peut-être oui faire valoir
leurs droits tout simplement je crois
que l'enjeu il est là la ministre l'a
rappelé tout à l'heure faire valoir
leurs droits et le premier de ces droits
c'est deêtre en capacité d'habiter de se
déplacer et de communiquer avec les
autres tout simplement on le voit le
chantier est bien avancé on va devoir
vous libérer d'ailleurs un calendrier
pour euh la fin de ce travau ouverture
euh nous tenons absolument le le le le
calendrier tel qu'il avait été fixé
l'ouverture est prévue dans 1 an euh en
septembre 2024 merci beaucoup Jean
vandrou